The Lord said to Abraham this is the beginning of the story
Get out of your country! And from the house of your family
And from your father's house
To a land I will show you
This is one of the sentences in which each paragraph is important
Go somewhere you do not understand
This is the first thing to get out of your country
You know in the 1920s
There were a large number of American writers. Those who were expelled to Paris, including Hemingwa
And who wrote "The great gatsby"?
Yes fitzgerald et al
The living was inexpensive in Paris at the time
And part of their transformation into great writers
The fact is that they were out of their country,
This made them see the real state of their country
Because you will not be able to see the state of your real country until you leave it
So you have to go into the unknown and this is God's first order
Go to the unknown
Because you know what you know
This is not enough unless you think you are giving up
If you are not perfect and do not think you are full you have to go to a place where you did not live
This is the first thing for Abraham
Well this is good and very logical
Go to where you do not know
What does it mean?
Well that's the meaning
It means keeping away from your family enough to be your independence
This is not because there is a defect in your family,
Perhaps there is perhaps a defect in you,
But that means get away,
You know I'm talking a lot to people who gave them their families extra protection
They know it themselves, it destroys the need (for something)
One of the things you see in America for example
That the children of the first generation of immigrants are better off than their children (second generation)
The reason for this is that first-generation children are driven by the need
You do not know how much you need to pay
Maybe I'm not disciplined enough
If you do not solve your problem directly if you do not act honestly today
If maybe you will never act honestly because of
Because the separation between your foolishness and punishment is accomplished by your unqualified wealth
So do not mature and do not learn and you
To get yourself out of your subordination to allow the need to push you forward
And become independent and mature
I think that is part of what happens in our culture
The force that attacks the current that goes in a straight line
When our youth are specifically afraid of the strength of men because they are confused
In the distinction between "power and power and power"
The man "efficient and powerful" gets power as a secondary product
But "efficiency and power" are everything
Those who do not understand this fail to differentiate between "power and power" and are afraid of power
They will destroy "efficiency and power"
And this is a terrible thing because we need competencies, what will make us lose others in the long term
If you move away from your country and from your family and from your father's house and go out and establish yourself in the world
It is an invitation to adventure
The first lines in the Abrahamic story are his call for adventure, great!
To a land I will show you
You know what this means?
I was deeply astounded by the number of writers Carl Jung and clearly one of them wrote things like Nietzsche
If you understand it you crash
And one of the things Jung understood and understood by mental analysts
It is one of the most daunting things in analytical psychology thinking and is strongly linked to religious thought
You are not the master of your house
There are souls living within you, that is
You have a will to be able to exercise some control over yourself
But there are many things happening within you
Look outside of your control
Your dreams, for example, are a good example
Or motives you might think they are strangers to you so you do not want to be part of you
But the most accurate is what about your tendencies, what drives you to want something
Where does this come from?
particulary ?
Because you can not bring your own inclination
If you are a student and study a difficult decision
You may tell yourself to sit and study for three hours
I sit down but do not happen what I wanted
Your attention is distracted and may say OK,
Attention from this if I could not control it
Because you say it's your attention
Well, if your attention was probably to be controlled but you could not!
You might say what's in control?
Maybe you think it's random, better not to be random
I can confirm this because it occurs in schizophrenia, there is a factor of random attention, your attention is not random
It is a course by which better phenomena are considered as characters under your personality and this is a partial description
You can not make yourself inclined to something, tendencies show up and then control you
This is quite different
What controls you?
How do you realize this? Is it something divine? He is my Lord because He controls you and can not do anything
There is an appeal within you that drives you and determines your tendencies and sometimes it is sometimes dark and may not be
But you are driven forward with what you tend to, if .....
if
The idea that moves you away from your home and your father's home and the welfare of your childhood in your country
It is something outside of you that you listen to, and listen
That's true
It can say I do not want to call this appeal to God or the Lord
It does not matter what you call it
It does not matter what is called, is an object and exists
If you do not listen to this other thing
If you do not listen to him, I have worked clinically and talked with enough people at my age to know this absolute knowledge
If you do not listen to this thing that drives you forward you will pay a price you could not imagine
You will get all the tragedies in your life and you will not find anything good in them
Worse, you will know
It is your fault that you lost what you could get